you know what's the crazy thing about
you know in America my dad says
if they want to see you fall in America
they'll do it America loves seeing a
personality fall but what they love even
more than that is redemption it's a very
big infatuation Americans have with that
so you think about Tyson coming out
knocking everybody boom he loses to
Buster Douglas oh my gosh Buster Douglas
this and then now he's coming back up
didn't want to see the new Tyson so
there's there's a part of anybody that's
going through the momentum the highly
highly exponential momentum Tyson
experience your experience you know it's
very it doesn't happen too often most
people they grow 12 24 they grow very
few go like this yours was exponential
but the part that's exciting most people
you're not 55 you're not 45 you're 35 36
years old which means the evolution
that's most exciting my watching you is
which I hope you don't take your foot
off the pedal I hope you push Full
Throttle with the you know uh with the
rumble I hope you follow keep going with
your content because you're gonna evolve
something's gonna happen in your life
the next five years you're gonna evolve
something's gonna happen by the time
you're 45 you're gonna involved and then
you're going to talk about different
things and some perspectives are going
to change some perspectives are going to
adapt that's what makes the Journey of
the hero exciting because everybody
learns as you're going through it
absolutely or not really and and that's
one of the most beautiful things about
being human and I was talking earlier
about the Redemption Arc and you
mentioned earlier in my final video how
I said I'm glad that this band happened
to me and one of the reasons I was glad
is because it gave me a chance to
address the consciousness of the of the
world there were certain rumors about me
which had spread like wildfire fire and
the unfortunate reality of the internet
is if there's a rumor about you no
matter how many times you dispel it if
there's more clicks and more interest in
perpetuating the rumor that's what
people are going to do and this ban is
to a degree a chance for a fresh start
because it allows me to discuss all the
rumors people talked about me hitting a
girl with a belt and me being a woman
beer that same woman has made three
videos subsequently three saying it was
consensual it was a long time ago he's
still a good friend of mine but no
matter how many videos she makes right
the video of her saying this is [ __ ]
gets 10 000 views and the video of me
being a movement beat or gets millions
of views that's the nature of the
internet so you need a mass extinction
event you need something big to happen
to address it the other big thing that's
against me is the fact that my house was
raided by Romanian police and people
talk about me being a people trafficker
and that's a really really interesting
one
it's interesting because I actually kind
of think it's a perfect storm some of
the other things I say about accessible
corruption or
the fact that I live in Romania which
has a bad reputation makes people think
ah so he's a criminal over there and he
can get away with it Etc let me tell you
something about Romania they have a bad
reputation for a few things
and one of them is people trafficking
which is age-old that was from the 90s
it's not the case anymore not at all
but they're very sensitive about it the
number one crime you'll get in trouble
for in Romania is exactly that it's it's
the one thing that they're very
sensitive about it's it's the image of
their country they're not going to allow
some guy to make their whole country
look bad it's like going to Dubai and
bragging about [ __ ] being the
financial criminal or something like no
no no no no that makes Dubai look bad so
that's the one thing you'll get in
trouble for
I wasn't doing it what happened was and
I've explained this at Lane I was
swatted loads of people have been
swatted someone called the police with a
fictitious story a complete false story
we were having a party our house there
was a bunch of girls there my brother
and I got bored decided to go to the
casino we don't gamble heavily but we
want to go play poker we went to the
casino left the party unattended there
was like 20 girls there on our pH
there's only girls in the house
this is all on CCTV this is the reason
I'm not in jail
the girl gets a phone call it's her
boyfriend
in America somewhere in Massachusetts I
saw you on Instagram story that's Tate's
house the girl who's from Miami actually
flew over to meet Tristan she messaged
you on Instagram the girl said oh uh
yeah but I didn't want to be here I I
I'm trying to leave and hung up
so her boyfriend
I don't know Sims bro I don't know if
you believed her I don't know if he was
jealous of us I don't know what calls
the American Embassy in Romanians and my
girlfriend's being held against her will
in this house now I have absolute
respect for the Romanian authorities I
would hate to live in a country where
they get a phone call saying a woman is
kidnapped and they don't bother to do
anything about it that would be a
terrible country to live in of course
they strapped up of course they turned
up they were very very respectful they
turned up they were all strapped they're
very respectful Andrew because I'm known
in the country Andrew Tristan we've
heard the support that it was a very
cordial conversation look around the
house no one's here we have CCTV in our
whole house they went to the cameras
they saw the girl on the phone go out
get a pizza come back get an Uber home
they're like well this is [ __ ] it's
like well obviously it's [ __ ] I was
small and a guy effectively was made up
a false reason to call me
took us to the police station do some
paperwork they came to the house
initially to search the house at five by
eight pm we went to the police station
news paperwork by 8 45 We Were released
that's it
no one talks about that Tate's house was
rated for human trafficking he was a
human trafficker his house is ready for
human trafficking I have no charges I'm
not on bail there's no criminal
investigation it's over it's done but
the nature of the Internet Hate being a
human trafficker gets clicks some girl
lying doesn't get clicks that's the
nature of the internet so I don't get a
chance to dispel these things unless
there was a mass Banning event and when
I was talking to my team saying look we
have to change the Public Image we have
to change the way create certain things
in the month before the ban we were
discussing how do we fix these rumors
and it's hard because especially when
you have massive detractors people who
hate me don't want to tell the truth
they hate me they just want to take
anything they can get to attack me like
I said they can't attack my physicality
or My Success so they have to attack
whatever they can get so there are
people on the internet who repeat the
same lie on repeat because that's all
they want to say so it was actually a
blessing in disguise so there's no
people trafficking charges I'm not
people trafficker the woman's come
forward so many times I don't beat women
like all these things are complete false
narratives and that's why the Banning
was a good thing because it allows me to
finally get everyone's attention and say
listen calm down
I know I I'm top GE but you can't just
be a human trafficker and run around the
world and not and get away with it like
there's that that's Insanity that's
that's great it's almost like a fresh
start clear the air all right after the
Smoke's gone let's see what we got it is
it's a fresh start and although I don't
believe my enemies and detractors are
logical enough and intelligent enough
and also non-emotional enough to accept
it's a fallacy and simply stop saying it
what it does do is the Matrix is fired
every bullet it has it's the empty clip
they fired the he's a people trafficker
thing it's been proven false they can no
longer repeat it they can't take the
bullet back and reload the gun and shoot
it again so instead of having it as a
nagging annoyance instead of having it
as a the old bow and arrow shot at me
for the rest of human time I'm glad they
shot me with the M16 and it's done and I
survived top G here I am and I can
finally understand that it can't be
repeated and it's finally gone away I
if anyone listens to my content I
Champion masculine strong men who
protect women that's what I chant that's
what I championed I say all the time
people trying to say I'm negative and my
mindsets are negative if you call a
police officer in the heat of battle you
want men Brave like me if you call a
fireman you want him to charge into a
burning building you want men with the
tenants I teach we are Protectors of
society we're absolutely not the
predators of society it are the people
who are my detractors the ones I talked
about who are objectively unattractive
and objectively unsuccessful they are
the predators not successful men I have
no need to kidnap anybody in fact
I begged them to leave my house
I'm like listen to parties up young lady
please go home so it's it's absolutely
insane and I'm glad I can finally clear
the air on that one if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as Kiyosaki Tate Connolly
parliamentary myself and others download
the app connect where you get a chance
to connect with these folks by the
minute you get to buy the minute or have
face times with them 15 minutes ask them
any questions you may want to have
download the app connect and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
foreign
[Music]